listen i want to i want to start with uh
a huge congrats on the movie um
and also being part of the toronto film
festival which is such an amazing place
to play movies um and i've so many
questions for everyone but uh i want to
know
what was it about this material that
said i want to spend what could be years
of my life making it
you know
it's so rare i feel that you know
what you want to make ties so deeply to
your own sort of personal or family
story um
i kind of put out into the world that i
wanted to do something around aviation
because my father was a naval aviator
when i was growing up so this this story
and getting to discover it has been this
really neat but odd opportunity to honor
the story of these two men but also in
this kind of weird way also tell my
dad's story glenn i have an individual
question for you um when did you decide
that you wanted to take every pilot role
from hollywood for so no other actors
could do it
i've always considered myself two months
for that
yeah this is the uh this is the top gun
mike this is the devotion
uh yeah yeah i think um i think i've
been told i'm not allowed to take any
more pilot rolls for a bit i'm being a
little selfish i think we it's time to
pass on uh pilot rolls with somebody
else right now does that rule out
astronauts
uh i've already played john glenn uh
true yeah you're right i gotta stay out
of the sky man i gotta i gotta put my
feet on the ground
that's for sure yeah but being serious
um what people might not know is you
were very instrumental in this project
getting off the ground and it was
something you've been working on prior
to top gun yeah i think it's been about
six years since i first read the book um
and it's been a process but i gotta say
that's been the dream
is to be here right now with the perfect
cast
perfect director we have the perfect
producers perfect studio and and really
people believe in this movie and it's
always been the dream it rarely works
out like this but
um
i made a promise to the hudner family
and the brown family that we were gonna
put this movie together and really honor
their legacy and i'm just so thrilled on
how it's come together
this is a question for everyone uh i'm
sure all of you read a bunch of scripts
you hear about things et cetera et
cetera what was it about this particular
project and this script and this story
that said oh i need to be a part of this
and this is for everyone i'll i'll jump
on that um
the title itself devotion
really really hit me as i was like that
it's kind of a secret word
it's a word that that we kind of only
hold on
to for ourselves you know and and
reading it i went okay this this script
is telling a secret
you know how do we survive as as a human
species how we survive as
uh in particular to
my character as a black man you know and
there is a certain amount of
secret devotion how you move through the
world how you treat other people how you
have to treat yourself uh in order to
move through it and uh i think every
character
uh has to come up against that in the
film and uh
no
none more than jesse and so that that's
what really grabbed me um to kind of
tell that secret and bring that to the
screen
you know
for me um i read it
and
[Music]
the story's amazing and it was beautiful
and
and vivid
um
the character of jesse
him choosing daisy as his partner
and
being that woman who carries on
so much for him when he's around when
he's not around um
i wanted it even if i didn't get it i
wanted to see it um and then actually
going through the process of making it
it was amazing just
finishing and seeing what we end up with
it was like that was that was i was
supposed to be here that was a good
choice this is
the love of the story
i just want to say without a doubt
because she's so beautiful
she's so incredible
thank you
i mean really it is it is like the
heartbeat of the movie that it's it's it
does not work without you and christina
just brings so much heart to this movie
it's incredible oh 100 i don't want to
do any spoilers but yeah if if the
audience doesn't buy into the two of you
and your relationship it's game over
absolutely i think this film has
everything i mean obviously there's a
beautiful love story
there's heroics there's heartbreak no
spoilers but there's a lot to this film
that i think people will really love and
from the book to the script to on screen
and jd's brilliance putting this all
together
it speaks volumes so
i can't wait to see it myself
no i think that it's really it's really
rare that you have an opportunity to be
part of
a project that actually honors
um a legacy
but it's not just a legacy of
two men who had an extraordinary life
but it is a it's a family that had an
extraordinary life and then it's a group
of friends and colleagues who had an
extraordinary life i mean the year
the year or two that these these people
all went through together
is is absolutely unbelievable you
couldn't write this script it could only
exist in reality
and
to be able to pay honor to
the people who lived it
every single day with each other uh is a
rare gift and i think you know from from
the instant i picked up the script into
the instant i put it down i knew that it
was something that i wanted to be a part
of you don't get those gifts very often
as an artist and and to be given it it's
incredible
yeah thanks glenn
thanks j.d
i appreciate everybody here appreciate
it
by the way i did get to talk to two
korean war medal of honor recipients
last night who literally said the
same thing which is
like in terms of the brotherhood in
terms of you know these guys aren't our
brothers or soul mates in terms of no
one knows you
the way
someone that you serve through hell with
knows you and so there's a connection
there's a bond there that i really feel
like this group embodies and it's hard
to describe but i feel like this movie
is the first movie i've ever seen that
really captures that i actually want to
single out um
thomas with
you're like wait what what i really
enjoyed the way your character and i
don't know how much is fact and fiction
how much is an amalgamation but that
your character in the film i really
enjoyed the commander because it was
written in a way that i was not
expecting it was very much uh
in your performance specifically it was
very much like a loving i love these
people these are my family and um can
you sort of talk about that aspect
because it's not the normal commander if
you you know what i mean
well you know dick civoli wasn't the
normal commander
um
i played the man as i understood him to
be
and uh you know we actually sat and
talked quite a bit about
um
making sure that
we didn't fall into the trap
uh that is so common in these sort of
movies um and that we actually honored
the man uh his family was very clear
about the fact that he was just this
incredibly loving spirit adam makos who
wrote the book uh was very clear about
the relationship that he had with the
brown family and and with the hunters
and with everybody who was in the
squadron it was he was just a different
kind of dude
and um
i think that it actually speaks to
jd's quality as a director as a
collaborator
that he believed enough in the reality
of the story to let it actually happen
you know that he didn't he didn't want
to fall down into a trope because it was
safe
because you don't know when you take a
risk of breaking a trope
uh if it's going to work and you know
that's up to the audience i guess
ultimately to decide but we had a hell
of a good time breaking it and i think
that it did a lot for all of us on the
day it opened things up in a way that we
allowed us to sort of play and have a
good time in ways that i don't think you
would normally get to see in this sort
of a film well it's the funny thing you
know like everybody has to be in the
same movie
and
you know starting with like the the
richness and depth that you know we kind
of center on jesse like if if the rest
of the cast of the rest of the
characters in that film are not
operating from a similar space or at
least operating with similar
authenticity you know i feel like that's
where the movie starts to fall apart um
so it was really this like start in the
center build out have these
conversations with everyone make sure
that you know we're bringing like as
authentic and honest a representation of
these people to the screen and then i
think that's what sort of then creates
this cohesion among the movie and
hopefully like this emotional honesty
you know no i i all in for me um this
question for all of you uh i would
imagine on every shoot
you're looking at the schedule and what
you have to accomplish each day there
must be one day on the shoot that you
have circled because whether or not it's
going to be a technically challenging
day an emotional performance something
where maybe you have to go deep in
yourself to deliver for each of you what
was the day on the schedule that you
either really nervous about or that
eventually my voice will you know i'll
grow through previously and um uh either
that you're either really nervous about
or just really excited about i think
there's always um
moments
when you show up and realize
at least on this set
that you're gonna lose somebody
and no spoilers i don't need to name
names but there's there's a motion that
we all have to go through especially
these guys that
spend
days on these decks when
wars are happening and lives are lost
every single day you don't know if
somebody's gonna land that plane and
make it back and so um
to get into that emotion it's just it's
never easy and it's um
it's it was an emotional rollercoaster
to say the least
uh for me
there are two i won't say one but um
it's the day in the kitchen where jesse
tells daisy that he's leaving
and
that conversation it's like we talked
about it's like this is what we work
towards and she's like no i get it but
like i don't want you to go
and just trying to find those notes and
that emotionality and knowing that yes
this is what he does and it means the
world to him and he's following his
purpose
and me as the actress getting into that
space where i am
fully on board with it but being true to
the emotionality that she is not and
that was a really really hard i remember
i was like i am
vulnerable right now
and so that was one for me i won't say
the other one beautiful to watch thank
you
it takes an incredible amount of courage
to do that on
film and you did it and it is beautiful
thank you
yeah absolutely
oh no that wasn't for anybody
thank you
i mean you know all
what maybe you know in a movie that has
like in-camera aviation and like a a lot
of sort of logistic complexity
i would say every day every day
every day yeah only all 57 days of
schedule uh no but
i mean honestly i think it really boils
down to and i still remember the c
numbers 125 and 127. um
it is in the officer's quarters
when
the two you are sort of expanding what
the notion of allyship means
um
and
like i don't care how many squibs we
have going off like how many explosions
or how many planes from 1950 we're
trying to put in the sky
the hardest part is telling an honest
story and
you know i think with the two of them
behind my this everybody but in those
two scenes that
these two gentlemen behind me i mean
a i couldn't have gotten through those
scenes without you know their sort of
prowess um
but i think going into the schedule and
even now being done with the movie uh
hardest thing is just to tell that story
honestly
i almost cried jesus oh no by the way jd
is the most emotional director i've ever
met in my whole life you literally have
over the monitor what do you want them
to feel which is which is a really rare
and special quality quality i um
i will say one of the one of the things
that i think there's those scenes in the
movie that people know
are foundational scenes but i think what
makes this movie
really special is that it's a it's a
it's an interesting sum of its parts and
some of these scenes that are really
they come across as small but they do so
much of the heavy lifting in terms of
character for the entire cast and i
think
it's interesting how some of the crew
like i don't know i don't know if you
feel like this but it's like some of the
crew comes up they're like hey big day
coming up oh yeah i hope you're ready
big day i'm like hey we cannot do that
i know i i i know i got it um but but
then there's these scenes that you know
as as we're we're diving into you know
story and character
the crew may not perceive this as to be
a big scene but we know it does so much
of the heavy lifting of what makes this
movie work so and those are the scenes
that keep you up at night for me
personally
if we have time
um
if we have time out i'll throw one in i
definitely want to hear it okay yes sir
um
i think for one this is our first
interview as a company and this is just
beautiful so thank you for for
moderating and being so warm and
allowing us to um
yeah it's big for us i guess um
but but to conclude the uh
the the scene in particular for me
um
wasn't necessarily a big scene because
it is it's just me and me and me you
know jesse and jesse um
but it was it was an expensive scene
because there's moments in films where
you you see the metal of the human being
you you we talked about the secret
earlier
that secret is completely exposed in
that moment and it's not pretty
and it's quite ancestral what he's going
through and oh um don't do it jay yeah
it's quite and you heard it
you heard it uh yeah
it's uh it's quite ancestral what he's
going through and
what he has to do in order to be a part
of
the brotherhood that he loves so much to
go back to his beautiful wife and child
you know that quiet ritual
um
it cost something and and shooting that
it was a big day because i was thinking
about
glenn joe tom christina jd
you know my work and having to conjure
all of that for that one moment um i
should i should mention to the audience
because they haven't seen it yet there
is a very powerful moment with you in
front of a mirror yeah and i think
that's what you're saying that's what
i'm discussing yeah yeah yeah and i just
want to let people know that when you
see the movie you will understand the
scene you're talking about i i was
watching it mesmerized because i was
just buying into your raw emotion on
screen but sorry i didn't mean to
interrupt well i mean what and and and
also to conclude that is why because
people are gonna watch that and and
though we may have different walks of
life
you've been there you told us earlier
hope you don't mind how you started this
by yourself so long ago and now it's one
of the biggest you know
you had to have conversation like that
with yourself
every one of us to get in this room to
get through the day have those
conversations and so uh
i would say that was a big see
just to say yeah that was like day two
yeah yeah
and then yeah i'm like yeah oh so this
is jonathan major's
god
i showed up early that day i remember i
wasn't even i was even supposed to come
till later and i just remember watching
that scene and being like oh my gosh
this guy's coming to play and i was i
was i was thrilled i never i i felt so
at peace about this movie after watching
that scene because this guy puts
everything he has into into every moment
of this movie i have to stop this
interview because they're going to
absolutely kill me but i will say that
that's
again i'm a very big fan of your work
and what you do on screen and the
performance in this film anchors a very
powerful story and i really want to say
congratulations to all of you for
delivering i i know people are going to
love the movie and i just want to thank
you so much for coming in and i wish you
nothing but the best for the rest of
your experience thank you thank you i
really appreciate it cool it's never
going to be better than this
you